[Music]
[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Francis H do Hey
mayor of the city of Cambridge is also
it is also my pleasure to welcome
Raymond F Malley Otzi class of 1972 and
Thomas L mell Yahtzee class of 58 hosts
of the National Public Radio series
cartel the Mariachi brothers will now
give the commencement address don't
crowd me glad you could all come shut up
[Music]
[Laughter]
this was announced in the miss happens
all the time
this is paper and my daughter my lovely
daughter Lydia who's sitting over there
called me and said is this true and I
said yeah she said when is commencement
I said it's June the 4th she said
promise me just one thing I said what
she's promise me that you'll think about
it before June 3rd which reminded me of
that great old country music song how
come you know me so good when I must
stranger to myself yeah well you want to
say well not much actually I just wanted
to say we are thrilled to be here with
you today and we especially want to
thank dr. vest and anyone else that he
might be able to implicate for having
the courage to invite us here
now I'm sure that we figured this is a
guy who has an ironclad contract I mean
you gotta really have him
well I'm sure those of you that know him
know that he is you know what
take-charge buck stops here kind of guy
I mean I know that because every time
his wife Becky has taken her automobile
to our shop for repairs he calls
personally to complain about the bill
and you know we were flattered to find
out I think just this morning that only
once before in the long history of MIT
has the demand for commencement tickets
been greater and coincidentally it was
when Abraham Lincoln spoke to my
brother's graduating class you know if
anything ever cried out for an
explanation it's why our Tom Andrade
speaking to us today and I will attempt
with the help of my brother to give you
some kind of an explanation I think you
deserve it
are you gonna be good I'm gonna be good
this all started a little over two years
ago we were doing our weekly radio show
and I happen to mention casually that
Kofi Annan had been selected to give the
address to the class of 97 Tommy says
Kofi Annan who the hell is he whatever
happened to old funk and then he begins
to rant
why did they choose Kofi Annan well okay
he is the secretary-general of the UN I
guess but no one's ever heard of him
everyone's heard of us they've got to
fly him in fly him out put him up on a
fancy hotel wining and dining and do all
all that they'd have to do none of these
things for us and and and and he's not
even an alumnus
now I will admit that I did participate
to some extent in his rant and rave I've
learned I guess most of the experts
agree that when you're dealing with
these irrational types that you
shouldn't be too confrontational in fact
you should try to be a little supportive
and then hope that the medication kicks
in well hardly a fortnight passes and we
receive in the mail from someone named
Charles M vest what I would call a terse
rebuke I wasn't so terse why haven't I
have it here read it to us please it's
the first one he really did click think
click 58 and clack 72 aha
now you know who we are I was sorry to
learn of your disappointment and not
being at you don't mind if we read these
we did clear this with your office what
can you do
[Laughter]
I'm sorry to interview disappointment at
not being asked to deliver the main
address at this year's commencement
exercise it had been my understanding
that you don't usually care for exercise
especially in the open air and that you
therefore wouldn't be interested in ours
on the other hand as alum me here so I'm
going with the great Gold Latin
pronunciation here on the other hand as
alumni you will appreciate the fact that
we have some fairly eccentric students
and faculty here at the Institute so the
idea of having you two gentlemen is
graduated graduation speakers is
invariably floated each spring this year
as always there was a strong but murky
and ECAR undercurrent of support for you
as commencement speakers still even your
most ardent back has had to admit that
there was one crucial area in which your
qualifications could not match those of
your fellow alumnus he isn't alumni
family what does that say well you of
your fellow alumnus UN Secretary General
Doug Hamish a Kofi Annan
72 he was a classmate of yours well I
was no no let's get this straight right
now I was class of 70 71 72 so I I
didn't I couldn't possibly have known
everyone no okay as you know the United
Nations has a really spiffy flag because
secretary-general Annan was featured as
this yes because we had a legitimate
excuse to fly the UN flag on the dais
and also to hang it anywhere else we
wanted to you can imagine how useful
such a flag can be when you want to
cheer up a drab corner of the campus or
decorate a really big space like an
auditorium or an athletic cage I mean
these are the kind of criteria that this
guy vest is using how is he thinking
if car talk or even Dewey Cheatham and
Howe had possessed a similarly
attractive flag we might have been able
to use you but as it was we felt that we
really had to go with the Secretary
General for us static reasons right you
will be pleased to know how of it that
Secretary General Anan was a great
success the graduating seniors were
especially moved when he described his
challenge at the UN as a little like try
trying to climb Mount Washington in a 63
Dodge dive he was also warmly applauded
when he urged the US Senate to give him
their share of the gas money for un
operations worldwide thus despite your
absence mi t--'s 97 commencement was a
smashing success please rest assured
we'll keep you in mind for future
ceremonies blah blah blah if you ever do
get a flag let us know yeah as you may
recall from your own graduations the
participants want to speak is to be
brief to the point I know that brevity
is not regarded as your most notable
quality finally I would like to urge you
to stay here it comes all that for this
last one line ending paragraph finally I
would like to urge you to start sending
us some really large donations
technically yours child's invest
president Bob blah blah blah blah
well a whole year passes without
incident well I shouldn't say without
incident during that year I think just
about every automaker on the planet
threatened to sue us but at least
without incident with regard to this
issue and then last year Tommy hears
that some elected official these are his
words remember from Arkansas who's been
in elected a feel it'll trouble with the
law is going to give the address of the
class of 98 as you can imagine another
rent and suits well doesn't take long
before Charles M vest puts laser printer
to paper and we receive another rebuke
but so I like to sound like a Bible
story which I also happen to have here
Chuck won't do you if we read this there
click 58 it collects 72 I understand
that you have once again expressed
on-air disappointment over not being
asked to speak at MIT s graduation last
summer I advised you that the chances of
being invited vited as commencement
speakers would be enhanced the car talk
had a suitable flag that could be used
to help us decorate the campus I hear
that you now have come up with a flag
and that you thought this would assure
your inclusion in the 1998 commencement
program
I mean we went out of our way if the
truth be known we got the flag yesterday
but we told him we had a flag we figured
he would be gullible enough he went for
it he were certainly it is possible at a
truly elegant flag along with you're
accountable yet undeniable popularity
among your fellow alums might have gone
a long way toward assuring a place for
you in this year's celebration except
for two rather obvious problems what
problem number one it says you failed to
show your new flag to anyone at MIT
minor detail now I don't doubt that the
flag exists well that's not entirely
accurate I do though
[Laughter]
but its existence does you no good if
you keep its secret there is after all
the reason why people use expressions
like let's run this up the flagpole blah
blah blah and the reason is very simply
that people cannot appreciate your flag
unless they can't see it now some of my
colleagues have suggested that the
contour flag may be based on some sort
of advanced stealth technology in which
case I applaud your technical prowess on
the whole however a stealth flag seems
to me a self-defeating innovation and
he's right about that problem number two
one of this year's commencement speakers
is the Honorable William Jefferson
Clinton president of these here United
States I paraphrase there as the duly
elected leader of the world's only
superpower mr. Clinton not only comes
with his own flag and a dime good one
too but he's even got a seal talk about
upping the ante heck this guy brings his
own podium audience press corps
helicopter you name it there's just no
way for the two of you to compete this
year you think you're disappointed not
even I get to make a speech this year
and I'm supposed to run the place
nonetheless he says I urge you not to
give up hope
send us pictures of this alleged flag
along with appropriate contributions to
alumni fund she said well the guy never
give up broken record isn't he good luck
I remain technically yours Charles and
vest well we got another letter by the
way I'm getting to that oh you are don't
interrupt
after these two letters of course Tommy
continues to rant al biet sporadically
he says because we haven't been chosen
and been overlooked by MIT he's lost
face and credibility you'd want to lose
a face like this wouldn't you friends
and neighbors have turned a cold
shoulder to him his wife and kids have
lost respect for him and barely talked
to him
even the dog won't play with him unless
he has a pork chop tied around his neck
then in the spring of this year
inexplicably we receive a beautifully
written I would say almost consumed
taury letter from doctor vest asking us
to speak to you today of course we've
lost that letter we don't know where it
is
but I do know that doctor vest figured
that we would have the dignity the good
sense and the respect for MIT to refuse
and to realize that the invitation was a
joke negative on all counts and of
course we accept but we become
immediately suspicious we start to think
how many others were asked before they
got to us I mean after all we knew and
let's we're not kidding anyone we are at
the bottom of the heap exactly right
we're at the bottom of the heap so they
must have asked me thousands of other
people so we engage our cracka detective
Paul murky of murky investigations to
find out who was asked and the reason he
or she refused I have the list this is
the impact
what these are the requests that he made
yes now due to certain treaty
restrictions and other strict protocols
we can't reaandtim
we can't read all the names but we do
have a few that we're allowed to read
and I will give you the name of the
person who was asked and the reason my
brother will give you the reason he or
she I've memorized the whole pile here
okay okay
Kofi Annan yeah he said been there done
that kissed one Oh a duo pons and
Fleischmann yeah they said very low
energy level we can't oh one of my
personal favorites leonid brezhnev I
love saying his name can I say it again
is it like a Rupa yeah leonid brezhnev
yeah he said he couldn't do it cuz he
was dead hey see oh yes dolly the cloned
sheep she couldn't come because she
didn't have FDA approval and last but
not least Leonid Brezhnev still there so
then he got to us I guess I guess so but
in spite of this news we're still
excited and thrilled of course and
honored to be here and after the
euphoria subsided I mean after the
euphoria subsided it began to sink in
that we actually had to give a speech
today and I will admit that I was
concerned and maybe even a bit worried
after all commencement speeches are
usually reserved for heads of state
respected members of the academic
community secretaries general of the
United Nations but us why us but my
fears began to ebb as I weighed the
consequences of a poor performance today
what if we do terribly what if we're
incoherent uninspiring mmm uninteresting
hmm just like our radio show
I mean what would could possibly happen
I mean what could they do
for our diplomas back they couldn't do
that could they I don't want to give my
diploma back I can't so it's holding up
the end of that table in your dining
room well after this epiphany I began to
feel a lightness of being and home and I
rolled up our sleeves put on a pot of
coffee and began the creative process
now he'll divulge the intricacies of
that process soon enough but first the
warnings I have to move this you know my
brother frequently makes what I would
call offensive and insulting statements
so my main function here today other
than introducing him is to number one
deflect any hurled fruit number two to
try to prevent him from insulting any
religious ethnic or paramilitary groups
to quell any civil unrest that may
result from anything he says or does and
to interrupt and clarify and say things
like well he didn't mean to say that
about every member of the faculty so
without further ado I would like to
introduce my esteemed brother
professor Thomas Marriott see well I
mean we have to use technology actually
can ice may I sit odd we figured I mean
this is a the world's foremost Institute
of Technology on Massachusetts Avenue
and so we ought to use technology so
what my brother did actually was he
requested from Paul para vano who's I
guess the second comprise the vice
president of MIT where is Paul and we
don't faith for him what he requested
copies of the last 20 years commencement
address
we gave this to our crack researcher
Palmer key of murky research brother of
the Palmer key of murky investigations
and we asked him to analyze all of these
speeches to find out if there were some
commonalities and indeed there were he
used factor analysis which the cost 15
guys will understand and he came up with
with three factors will get this every
one of these speeches had in common a
beginning a middle and an end
powerful well this is good because we we
were so thrilled at this that we had
made such progress that we put it aside
for about a month didn't have to think
about it anymore then we looked at it
one day and said this is a little skimpy
so I hate they threw up but but the good
news is our wives are not hanging their
heads in shade yet they will okay go
ahead we figured the beginning that was
pretty straightforward we could read a
couple of letters from chuck best so we
did that already
and so that's done the middle that was
the tough part we couldn't quite figure
what the middle ought to be but the end
we knew had to be some kind of
inspirational thing right that's what
they all are so we said to ourselves
what do we know about inspirational
things
it so happens however man it so happens
that we have in addition to murky
investigations murky Palmer who I just
told you did the factor analysis had
been working on some other research for
us and he and his lovely assistant Marge
in Oh Vera Marge
you know they're yeah they got it I
think it just wasn't that funny I'll
tell you the Genesis it's interesting
how research happens one day I can't
remember which one of us it was I had
come across interestingly isn't it
interesting I mean coincidence we just
had a little Hebrew prayer and one of us
had thought of a quotation for one
another great Hebrew philosopher Isaac
Newton and if you recall what you
probably don't because you're a bunch of
nerds who only think in numbers top it
behave
he said if I have accomplished anything
in my life it is because I have stood on
the shoulders on the shoulders of giants
Wow that's what we said Wow
but after a few moments we thought about
it a bit and said you know it's one of
those things you know like George Colony
says sounds good and we won that is it
in fact true in all areas of endeavor
that people accomplish great things
because they stand on the shoulders of
giants so we tell Paul murky do some
research on this and he comes back to us
with a couple of hypotheses you know
he's a great researcher this man the
null hypothesis is of course it applies
to all areas all endeavors because we as
humans have been on the planet for
hundreds of thousands of years and we
each benefit from whatever has been done
by our predecessors
that's the shoulders of giants
hypothesis the alternative hypothesis is
oh yeah it's not true in some areas yes
we do in fact benefit from what our
predecessors have done but in other
areas
mostly might like the human involvement
kinds of areas we may in fact all be
destined to make the same mistakes over
and over and over again generation after
generation child after child and so
there is never any giant on whose
shoulders you could stand and therefore
there is no progress now there is an
interesting set of hypotheses this one
is called the oh yeah alternative
hypothesis so murky goes out and starts
to work and as he will do murky doesn't
stick strictly to what we asked him to
do and one day we catch him
I think it's called mucking around in
the data and sure enough he comes to us
and says guys I have been mucking around
in the data and I have a finding here
that is gonna knock your socks off and
we have I have to apologize for our
visual aids here I did have prepare a
complete PowerPoint presentation and I
asked for an overhead projector and they
couldn't find one yeah no I think they
told them to drop dead could I have a
slide number two please okay Chuck come
on Chuck
where are you buck here earn your money
I already I already used that one yeah I
just took it off from right back
don't fall off now what those on the
back with the cheap seats you can't see
this but it's very straightforward I may
have to move over to this mic does this
might work yes it does
Murphy says to us I've plotted something
interesting here we're talking about
basically left brain versus right brain
function he says and while mucking
around I find this interesting
relationship this is left brain on this
end this is right brain on the right
this well tell you that this is a plot
he did a regression analysis on this
with an r-square of 0.99 and a
significance of 0.0001 and this this
axis is happiness doesn't that knock
your socks off he says left brain right
brain and if you think about it this is
sort of what we think of some people do
at least intelligence so it's almost a
plot of intelligence versus happiness
and the news ain't good for you because
what murky finds out is that right brain
people are about 10 times as happy as
referring people so the stupid you get
by left-brain people's measures of
stupidity of course because right brain
people are too happy to waste their time
developing IQ tests but they're ten
times happy we say
Paul this is something but that's not
the end of it because we Sweden what any
good researcher would do we want to
extrapolate and do we want to
extrapolate in this direction hell no we
want to extrapolate in that direction so
we say to Paul if this really is
intelligence going in that direction
what we need is Dumber people let's see
if it goes on and on so where do you go
he goes to Harvard he comes back to us
about a month later and he says it just
isn't working he said they're not dumb
enough and I say what do you mean
they're not dumb enough they don't get
me dumber than Harvard students and he
says people don't get any dumber than
Harvard students but why do we have to
limit our research to people oh sure
used to live oh I'm sorry so I'm just
trying to drive the guy with the
microphones great so he says I can
extend the research to include other
life-forms and through a methodology
which he will not reveal to us he was
able to determine the happiness level of
other life-forms slide 3 please 3 slide
3 here it is he is humans and the best
of humans of course is the right brain
humans and here is what he found
happiness goes up it begins to look like
it's exponential over there
the next happier life-form is a golden
retriever
then a cow
then words and he stopped his research
at grass you can show the faculty
because they they may not understand
what I'm talking about now here's the
story I mean what is the importance of
this we have always thought that we were
the highest life form on the planet
turns out we are the lowest life form on
the planet and I am going to give to you
now a theorem which will knock your
socks off some theories you know I just
complete [ __ ]
for example the Big Bang Theory the
entire universe is compacted into a dot
it explodes why well they don't know why
so they call it a singularity that's
like the bimbo saying well it just did
it explodes and out of it come all the
stars that you can see in the sky all
the planets Madonna
corned beef sandwiches now if you didn't
hear that and say oh come on but I am
going to give you the theorem and you're
gonna say why didn't I think of that
what does all of this tell us that we
are not the highest life form this is
the theory of reverse incarnation I mean
some people believe in reincarnation and
what they believe is that when we die we
come back as better and better people
what the theory of reverse reincarnation
says if we are good people we will come
back as a golden retriever then a cow
then a worm then grass now if the
reincarnation was working in the other
direction coming back as better and
better people where are they duh so it
becomes clear that the theory of reverse
reincarnation may be the scientific
finding of not the decade not the
century but of all time now my brother
and I Elrond while Yahtzee are going to
help you to achieve Nirvana we're going
to help you to get to become not smarter
smarter is no good that's the wrong
direction you've been doing that you
have spent the last four five or six
years of your life working on the wrong
direction you are sliding down as Tom
Lehrer says sliding down the razorblade
of life you are sliding down the
happiness curve you must stop this from
happening and you must go in the other
direction and we are here to help you
and as you know there is a process for
reaching nirvana and we are going to
give it to you now it is this you must
repeat the mantra and the mantra which
happens to be emblazoned on our flag
which stands here none of you morons
will be able to read it because it's in
Latin it says non in PDT Rati Oni kaga
Tatiana's which of course beings
unencumbered by the thought process
now I am going to give you a very brief
history of how this mantra has helped me
I can't wait if you repeat this mantra
what happens is everything slows down
life slows down being unencumbered by
the thought process allows you to
identify and hear and see defining
moments in your life things that will
change your life
unencumbered by the thought process you
say it over and over again
and as everything slows down and begins
to stop
we call these by the way moments of
inertia god is that bad I had to use it
though I had to I I was once trapped by
the scientific logic left brain life I
graduated from here and I went to work
as an engineer and I will tell you about
my defining moment I was driving I lived
in Cambridge at the time I was driving
from Cambridge to my job in Foxborough
Massachusetts and I was driving in a
little mg weighed about 50 pounds and on
route 128 I was cut off by a semi and I
almost as they say bought the farm and
as I continued my drive I said to myself
if I had in fact bought the farm out
there in 128 how taked off would I be
that I had spent all my life that I can
remember at least going to this job
living a life of
desperation so I pulled into the parking
lot walked into my boss's office and I
quit on the spot see now most people
would have just bought a bigger car ya
see but those people would have been
using their left brains I had been
saying my mantra in the car that's why
the guy cut me off I think I cut him off
in any event I quit my job I became a
bomb I spent two years sitting in
Harvard Square drinking coffee I
invented the concept of the
do-it-yourself auto repair shop and I
met my lovely wife none of which would
have happened if I had been using my
left brake my second great defining
moment came also showing the power of
the mantra unencumbered by the thought
process I was having an argument with my
lovely wife one day I mean how can you
argue with such a wonderful person
well left-brain people do that because
all they can think of is this is an
argument this person is over here and
I'm over here and I am going to use
every ounce of logic and skill that I
have so that I can win this argument and
my wife says to me if you want to be
right I'll do you want to be happy
holy-shit says I I wanted to be happy so
now I have reached Nirvana and my
brother and I can help you to reach it
if you want to repeat after me
unencumbered by the thought process say
you may have to stand for this
unencumbered by the thought
Russell Aude come on unencumbered by the
thought process one more time
unencumbered by the thought process
follow us my children to happiness oh
yes
are there any questions
[Laughter]
thank you you happy I'm excited
Thank You professor Wagstaff that was
most informative you know that does
remind me of a famous Latin expression
hi sir see we were at a drayman der eros
which means if Caesar were alive you'd
be chained to an oar look we won't
belabor this any more than we have to
but this is the part of the address
where we're supposed to say something
meaningful and impart some words of
wisdom
oh we're not sure but I'm not sure that
we're in possession of any wisdom but
we've never let that stop us so listen
up I'm only gonna say this a few times
today you will receive a document that
states that you've earned the degree or
maybe degrees from MIT you know you've
worked hard and you should feel a great
sense of accomplishment I know I did and
most of you will leave here today with a
pretty good idea of where you're going
and and what you're going to do some of
you have no clue and you'll just have to
move back in with your parents if they
if they have it rented out your room
already
but others among you may have charted a
course or had one charted for you that
you know is wrong and you may feel some
creative energy coursing through your
body don't ignore it if you feel the
urge to create and discover and to do
something that will bring you
fulfillment and happiness do it now
while you're young you will never have
more energy or enthusiasm hair
or brain cells than you have today do
you know when when Albert Einstein was
less than half my age
he was already world-famous for his
special theory of relativity when Isaac
Newton was less than half my age
he was already famous for having
invented calculus and he pretty much had
written your entire 801 physics textbook
Mozart when he was half my brother's age
had been dead for three years so act now
lastly I've skipped a bunch of things
because god I just want to encourage you
to never get so involved in your work
whatever it is that you forget to have
fun you know my brother may be right if
you're lucky you may come back as a
Mouser or a Bichon Frise but you may not
I mean with all this spaying and
neutering going on than the old odds are
getting worse and worse every year
so have fun now and enjoy yourself and
I'd like to leave you with some words of
a wise man wise man from the east
my brother and I know all wise men are
from the east if you ever met a wise man
from the West or the middle they're all
thinking real birds from the West and
and this wise man is no exception except
he's from East Boston and his name is
Deepak Fonzarelli
and quite I'm quite a man he is quite a
man and Tommy and I go to him from time
to time to learn the answers to Watie
questions like what is the meaning of
life what are next week's winning
lottery numbers going to be and we went
to him recently and Tommy and I sat with
him and Tommy asked him how he could
attain immortality
deepak sat for a minute got up and
turned off the TV
Baywatch it just ended and he said my
son if you wish to attain immortality
you must do the following you must work
hard every day seven days a week never
taking time off you must attend no
social functions you must not smoke
you must not drink and you must not go
with women huh never had we received
such a definitive answer to any of our
questions we were astounded and Tommy
asked and Tommy asked I say the Deepak
you mean if I do those things I will
live forever oh no my son he said it
will just seem like forever have fun
enjoy the ride and don't drive like my
brother congratulations brother thank
you
you